[Música]
vamos a la revista de prensa con Rosa
Pérez más de u Rosa Buen día para usted
Buen día Ángela por supuesto Cómo no
vamos a empezar con Francia la prensa de
ese país habla sobre la promulgación de
la Reforma de las pensiones y el
discurso de macron que estamos esperando
para el día de hoy vamos a empezar este
repaso con lemons exactamente Ángela no
un poco a la expectativa de lo que pueda
decir Emmanuel macron para apaciguar un
poco la situación en Francia lomo titula
macron promulga la ley como bien decías
la reforma de las pensiones la protesta
continúa y señala este periódico francés
que macron y que no logró la petición de
los sindicatos de que no promulgara la
ley y que precisamente las
organizaciones sindicales y hacen un
llamado a una movilización masiva de
cara al 1 de Mayo el día del trabajo
para continuar contestando esta ley que
sin embargo ya está definitivamente
aprobada y validada no después esta
Liberación sí que titula sos democracia
una portada muy contundente que se basa
en un sondeo que ha realizado este
propio medio de comunicación que señala
que el 76% de los franceses consideran
que la democracia francesa está en mal
estado de salud además según este mismo
sondeo que está en portada de liberación
uno de cada dos franceses el 50% de la
población considera que la forma de
ejercer el poder de Manuel macron es
autoritaria y siguen las portadas
También tenemos la grúa sí que dice un
quinquenio que relanzar nunca ingenió en
relación En referencia a este mandato de
5 años en el segundo mandato de Manuel
macron no que se encuentra solamente en
este primer año en medio de una crisis
que algunos consideran crisis política
otros social otros democrática otros de
legitimidad Lo cierto es que los datos
según una última encuesta del 12 de
abril de ipsos para luan Manuel macron
se encuentra en el punto más bajo de su
popularidad desde desde hace cuatro años
no desde la crisis de los chalecos
amarillos que también puso al entonces
bastante nuevo nuevo presidente contra
las cuerdas Y es que el 69% de los
franceses tiene una opinión desfavorable
respecto a Emanuel macron una cifra que
todavía es peor si hablamos de Elizabeth
de la primera ministra y lo que queda es
camino vamos con el Fígaro Sí
exactamente que dice macron Quiere pasar
página sin cambiar de rumbo no una vez
más En referencia a que El Ejecutivo
quiere ya pasar a otra cosa dejar atrás
esta impopular reforma de las pensiones
pero que la el problema para la sociedad
francesa continúa siendo esta falta de
digamos esta forma de gobernar tan
autoritaria como señalaba el señalaba
Liberación bueno Y usted decía que
dependiendo de la voz que se escuche
pues la crisis es considerada de una
manera diferente en Francia en una
editorial de media parte se habla de el
presidente sin escrúpulos que lleva a la
pérdida de la República una acusación
bien grave sí Y es una acusación firmada
por el director de este medio de
comunicación el periodista muy conocido
en Francia Edwin Planet que dice que
este proyecto de presidencia de macron
abre la puerta a la extrema derecha
porque acostumbra la sociedad francesa a
su violencia antidemocrática y a su
ideología antigualitaria que no es la
primera acusación de este tipo que se
hace sobre el tema Rosa Exacto vamos a
cambiar de tema con el Washington es un
tema que ha sido digamos muy taquillero
en los titulares y es el porqué un joven
de 21 años tenía acceso a documentos top
Secret a propósito de la noticia que
conocimos la semana pasada exactamente
hablamos de
El acusado de la filtración masiva de
documentos del pentágono que es un chico
de 21 años que trabajaba en una base
militar porque formaba parte de la
inteligencia de la guardia nacional
aérea y concretamente era trabajador del
área de informática por lo que explica
el Washington post que es normal que
tuviera este tipo de acceso a cierta
información
clasificada porque como él
aproximadamente un millón de personas
según el post tiene autorización para
acceder a sitios con información
clasificada y explica este medio
estadounidense que bien Es necesario
pasar una revisión bastante exhaustiva
de la vida privada antes de que te
autoricen a tener acceso a información
confidencial pero que estas pruebas que
pueden incluir hasta la prueba del
polígrafo se hacen cada cinco años y que
es normal que para además alguien joven
No sus relaciones y sus motivaciones
cambian Sin que los controles digamos
los protocolos pues estén un poco al
corriente bueno y hay muchas teorías de
alrededor de Por qué sucedió esta crisis
no de seguridad para el país el titular
es Jack de sospechoso de filtrar
documentos víctima de Lego exactamente
explica Macarena vida la periodista Que
firma este artículo que según los
veteranos de inteligencia hay cuatro
razones principales que llevan a que
alguien robe inteligencia Y hacia otras
personas una razón sería la codicia la
segunda el chantaje hacerlo o recibirlo
la tercera el idealismo o la voluntad de
hacer justicia y el cuarto lugar el ego
o el afán de Gloria y que este habría
sido el caso no de El acusado de esta
filtración masiva de documentos del
pentágono que recordémonos recordemos
hacia sobre todo referencia a la
situación de la guerra en Ucrania y
titula bueno señala la periodista que a
diferencia no de otros de otras personas
que han filtrado información
recientemente como Chelsea Manning no
que pasó miles de documentos a Wikileaks
que en ese momento pues tanto ella como
snowden que reveló el espionaje masivo
del Estado estadounidense a los
ciudadanos Pues que a ellos les movía
una cierta voluntad de justicia y
rápidamente el global Times algunos
medios de comunicación occidentales son
muy poco profesionales eso dice sí
básicamente lo que pide el global Times
es que En referencia a la visita de el
ministro de defensa de China a Rusia que
los medios occidentales paren de Crear
alarma dejen de considerar esta cita
como una voluntad no de reestructurar el
orden internacional y que dice es normal
la preocupación occidental respecto a la
guerra en Ucrania pero china no es parte
del conflicto y deben dejar de
responsabilizarla bueno Eso depende de a
quién le pregunte usted también según
los analistas Gracias Rosa y vamos con
más noticias